I would never ask a monthly but it would
be outside of my realm bro if you notice
when I get the light I get all yeah I
don't disrespect so don't ever [ __ ]
disrespect me won't know that a mother
looking bro that's why I do that I
respect comics with the utmost [ __ ] I
was thinking about a weed story be a day
I used to open like he was talking my
hosting uh-huh I used to host all the
time on Sundays I used to host and work
the door for 25 bucks that's how much
Mitch he would like that works a back
door and then go host at the same time
why I didn't forget I told his kids
because the microphone was broke of a
Sunday night it was like 60 people in
there and I said before he went on stage
I took all the open mic visionary I'm
that list go do me a favor
don't touch the microphone and there was
this one kid I told my Kent I don't know
wait does this mother [ __ ] what happened
didn't I still my Cassie broke so he
broke it there was no microphone in the
rest of it I had to go get a microphone
from the [ __ ] belly room it didn't
work and I kept fiddling and that mother
[ __ ] came out I said so until I got
this [ __ ] face because he
disrespected all of us man
well I need to take no we just told you
not to touch the [ __ ] microphone you
know we had to go to La Hoya one weekend
he kept calling the store they used to
beat me up his buddies they set up a
pool hall law and a little pool tape man
and I used to have a pool table took all
the balls out of it let strategically
put them in the flower pots outside Adam
in my pockets I took all the cue balls
Chuck Norris style and see this a gallon
thought about Brooklyn was thinking
about who shot Bobby Lupo
I said sticks I hit pipes I went behind
the barn I got a knife I think I know
why they tend to pull him on it took the
flow pipeline I hit everything bro and
these dumb [ __ ] got together and they I
saw the car at the top of the hoy and
I'm in frozen converse door and they're
right there they gonna make a left and
they man I'm behind the door I'm waiting
for them to come down I'm making believe
like I'm smoking a cigarette I don't see
him they come around the turn they come
shooting down and as they kind of pull
up [ __ ] water gun out like those big
spray guns I take the [ __ ] cue ball
and I just movin at them and it hits the
side door me goes
boom they thought a missile hit him they
didn't get a shot to shoot me with the
water pistol
they took often called Hollywood commie
stones that Joey Diaz through a cue ball
a decision mr. wall what I feel like two
years of being used to look at don't
even do come in a walk there's like 15
years ago he [ __ ]